hello that's it going thank you for the
intro Thank You Christine
so honeycomb is a tool for helping you
understand your complex software systems
what does that mean what does that look
like well right now you're a software
engineer in the industry maybe some of
you have experienced this at internships
when you're trying to figure out what's
happening in production you typically
have two types of tools you have
monitoring tools which give you graphs
which give you dashboards where you you
scroll through lots of things until you
find maybe what graph that spikes in an
interesting way and then you can kind of
look for other graphs that let you
that's like in an interesting way or you
have logging tools which deals kind of
all the text output from your normal
from your normal applications and you go
hunting for that needle in the haystack
that will tell you what went wrong
honeycombs thesis is that these are two
things that have sort of evolved in a
direction that made sense from the
constraints that we had in the 90s we
had when you had grep when you had
counters when we were like alright well
you know CPU and memory are very very
expensive so we're going to do
everything very cheaply
it is not 2019 it is terrible to be
constrained by the things that people
decided 20 years ago 20 plus years ago
so with honeycomb we're saying you can
have both you can have not only these
graphs that we're used to but also all
the fidelity all the extra metadata all
that useful information in your logs
that told you what happened you can have
them together we use the word events
just to describe things that are
happening in our system and we talked
about honeycomb as letting you finally
see your production system in high res
meaning you can you can see the big
picture and then zoom in and get really
close and understand why and what and
how to fix what's going on with your
software to give you a little bit of an
idea of why honeycomb why now we're
really seeing a few kind of overwhelming
trends in the software industry right
now
one technology you know the only the
only constant is changed so on and so
forth there's a bunch of Technology
choices that have that are becoming
popular that are changing how people are
deploying software and maintaining
software containers micro-services
kubernetes all of these pieces of
technology mean that the average
software system these days has more
moving parts it's harder to keep track
of which pieces are interacting with
which other pieces and where where the
problem is coming from along with that
while technology is often the catalyst
we're also seeing changes in the process
of engineering teams agile has been
going on for a while but things like CIA
CD are changing how people think about
how they commit to master how they push
changes to production and finally people
where we're literally seeing you know
people are now defining themselves as a
DevOps team because they're recognizing
that the boundary between developer of
I'm going to write some code and push
the master when I'm done and operator
the people who have to maintain that
software once it's in production they're
saying that line blur and they're
they're looking for ways to bridge those
two disciplines they're previously
thought to be completely different
disciplines and with these changes we're
finding people are finding that their
tools are currently outdated so to give
you an idea of what people are using
honeycomb for we're company's been
around for three years we have a number
of customers that have used us to change
how they're shipping software often
people come in first for an incident
response news case they're finding out
that when they're experiencing downtime
their current tools aren't giving them
answers as to why they can tell them
they can tell the engineering teams that
something is wrong but they can't figure
out you know the combination of factors
that are actually causing an incident
allow them to resolve the incident
that's often what brings folks to us
that that's often what gets us in the
door but more and more we're seeing
people use honeycomb not just to figure
out why their code and production is not
behaving as expected in an incident
context but more like why isn't it as
fast as I expect why isn't my code
efficient as I expect okay well let's go
look at what's what it's doing
let's go look at you know outliers and
why my software might be behaving in a
certain way and then we're seeing this
cool use case is cool flywheel of
engineering teams folding honeycomb into
their development processes using it to
drive decisions about what could right
in the first place what normal is what
use cases or customer use cases to build
for and really seeing this really cool
virtual cycle virtuous cycle build in in
their development processes in order to
ship better code not just faster like CI
CD promises but also being able to ship
with more confidence that your code will
do what you expect it to do and once it
hits production to give you very
high-level overview of where honeycomb
sits and what it actually does we ingest
a bunch of data
this is logs agents in your code
whatever we ingest a bunch of data we
have a custom column store both on SSDs
that column stored lets us slice dice
analyze visualize it gives you insight
into your data so that you can start to
ask questions about okay well why do
latency spike
oh well which end point did it spike for
which customer did it spike for is there
some strange you know it is is it being
impacted by one of my instances
rather than the entire cluster and this
I have included a video which may or may
not work just what honeycomb looks like
did it do it and it seems like it is
going is so I guess it's a slice and
dice by some 90 in this case previous
we believe in tools that I'll just
answer but I'll point you in the right
direction what we've done here is user
has said tell me what's special about it
we've gone through and we've that user
ID one user that pops out in that
highlighted section and then as your
understanding of what's happening in
production of my balls go in like
through find a trace of a single
execution get down to this level of
detail that really helps me understand
what my code is doing and I can continue
that I can continue that cycle I can
take what I've learned here feed it back
into this higher-level question of why
is my code not behaving the way I expect
this is a recycled deck our customers
love us and to give you an idea of where
how far how far we are what we've been
working on Honeycomb has been in
existence since the very beginning of
2016 first year we really spent building
out our prototype and establishing the
market and this is something that lots
of entrepreneurship classes will not
will tell you not to do but what we
really saw is when we looked at the
market
people wanted log tools or they wanted
monitoring tools because that's what
they were used to looking for so we
started talking about hey observability
is this thing that isn't really captured
by what your tools currently allow
observability is about asking new
questions of your systems as well as the
processes and and culture that supports
it 2017 and 2018 has been taking that
prototype these ideas this excitement
really starting to land turn our kind of
early adopters into customers seeing
traction loading lots of lessons about
GTM especially as a developer tool in a
b2b market and right now we're we're in
the stage where we're really trying to
feel like we've really grown up kind of
out of our awkward teenage phase into
our young adult phase of we know what we
we know what we're doing we know what
our value prop it is we know who we're
talking to and now we just got to now we
just have to show that it's repeatable
and
go out there and kill it that's where we
are thank you for listening to the
context and now we can do a little
interview session with the group
fantastic intro before I kind of get
into some of the formal questions you
and I were having a little bit of a chat
before you were talking today and I was
sharing with you about where I started
off on a technical track and ended up
moving into a product management check
but you're not she talked a little bit
about that you were heavy on the
technical side lots of students that I
interact with one of the top questions
that they ask is do I stand a technical
track do I go on a product track should
I do both when would I do both but
you've had a really interesting
perspective on that I thought that big
great way to open up awesome to give you
an idea I had a yes degree I have been a
software engineer I identify as a
software engineer been working for about
10 years for the last I would say for
the last two years what I've primarily
been doing it's not software engineering
but all that software engineering
experience has really helped me
understand the problem domain in the the
folks that were working with right it
lets me go to customers and really
understand their problems understand
what their software developing practices
might be like because I've seen I've
been professional software engineer in
enough different environments that I can
start to you know understand what is
normal what is not and it really helps
has really helped me build up when
working with customers and understanding
of the right phrases to pull on if
you're doing customer development you're
talking to a customer they're telling
you about their problems there's certain
phrases that I'm much better at at being
like Oh tell me more about that a
salesperson or someone who's less
familiar with software might not be able
to very cool so one of the main the top
reason why startups fail is because of
lack of product market fit and that's
the most difficult thing to figure out
you think you've identified an unmet
need in the marketplace and it turns out
wasn't really a problem in the
marketplace or there was other
competitors in the space or you saw the
need differently so last time
checked I think you guys raised over 15
million dollars you're generating
revenue but tell me word about where
this idea came from and how you sort of
took it from this initial seed of an
idea and got it to a company that's now
generating revenue and has done really
well in raising some some capital
awesome honeycomb started because I was
started from myself and my co-founder
charity working together at a company
called parse which was about Facebook
and a parse we were dealing with tons of
unmitigated chaos they just we're a
platform that allowed mobile developers
to basically include a black box and
suddenly get all the benefits of having
servers and databases and everything it
meant that it's great for our users they
loved us we had to deal with their chaos
and we had to deal with oh gosh this
shared resource is being slammed who was
being slammed by why who else is it
impacting and how can we put a bandaid
on it so everyone else the service is
undamaged
and this this this question of what's
happening why let's tease it apart and
isolate isolate the the problems that I
talked about in that demo that's exactly
what charity and I and the other folks
in the parse team we're doing day to day
we got bought by Facebook one of the
things that happens when big companies
buy little companies if they kind of pat
you on the head they're like oh you're
so cute here are the big kid toys and
the Facebook most of them were garbage
for our use case great for Facebook's
use cases not for ours but one of them
stood out it was called scuba and it let
us really quickly slice dice understand
our system in a way that changed how we
built how we we maintained our software
how we built our software moving forward
and I think for us really the impetus
behind this was thinking about going
back out there
away from Facebook largest software
industry and not having this tool at our
fingertips because we dispensed you know
we had our battle scars from trying to
solve these sorts of problems with
traditional monitoring tools traditional
logging tools and it was just so painful
that we were like this must exist I
think the thing that we think that
becomes easy to discount when a startup
idea comes out of that environment
is how how much easier it is to push
adoption inside an organization versus
outside right Facebook has a luxury of
saying ah well new engineer here the
tools you're going to use this is why
these are the trade-offs and these are
the only tools you get to choose from a
little different out here in the real
world but it's been a lot of fun kind of
being it's been a lot of fun being able
to start off with that conviction of we
know that this is the right problem to
solve that this is the right approach
because we've lived it we we ourselves
our true believers yeah so tell me a
little bit about how the founders came
together how you started thinking about
roles and responsibilities and in that
dynamic cuz that's the second reason why
startups fail wrong people are involved
or they're in the wrong position and
that's another really hard part to get
right yeah so charity and I had worked
together for a few years at parce before
jumping into this together and we
actually didn't spend a ton of time
working directly she was the first infra
hire eventually ran it back in software
engineering team I was a product
engineer who built our analytics product
and most of our interactions early on
were like me shipping something and then
her being ops coming in everywhere
knocking on my door and being like
Christine this thing broke help me fix
it and so it's it's funny because that
that relationship that we had was almost
is almost the sort of exact sort of
relationship were trying to break down
now with something like honeycomb but I
think that we had a lot of mutual
respect for each other
both working on this product that we
loved that we cared a lot about and
we're especially excited to work with
each other on a tool like honeycomb
because we both feel like we brought
dramatically different perspectives in
an important way that would help us make
sure that we shipped the right the right
product in the end
right ultimately honeycomb is a tool for
software engineers with operational
responsibilities or operational
sensibilities
we call them software owners people who
are comfortable in code comfortable
shipping code
but ultimately want to be responsible
for how that code continues to behave in
production so we're excited to work with
each other for those reasons we're
bringing those kind of different skill
sets the table we I think when we
started out we were not we were not the
sort of people to be like oh well five
years down the road we're going to be a
200-person company and you should be CEO
and I'll be CTO and we'll have buddies
like giant organizations underneath us
we were very pragmatic we're very just
like ok these are these roles that need
filling right now one of us has to be
CEO and none of it will really matter
because for this first year we just need
to build build stuff and so charity kind
of reluctantly took on the burden of
being CEO and I say burden because
that's how she felt you know we were
engineers going and and developing
relationships with CEOs and sorry
developing relationships with investors
and figuring out his cell are not are
not things that really were exciting to
us at the time we wanted to build a
product that would change how people
like us would would do their jobs and I
think it was actually perfect in the
beginning because charity had spent so
much time as an operator kind of
developing this public voice she did a
lot of speaking before with her work
through
and was very well practiced at going out
there and industry and saying hey guys
there's gender neutral guys there's
something like different there can be
there's there's something you can be
doing your jobs differently there's this
new future
I've seen it guys it's so great over
here guys gender neutral and especially
when our first year was spent building
up the market building up the
understanding of why observability
mattered and why honeycombs approach was
important I think it was great to have
her kind of more publicly out there
myself more focused on the product in
the last this spring we actually sort of
changed roles so I'm now CEO she is CTO
Wow
and I think that it you know feels
on one hand feels like a big change
right well changing roles like what is
that what's that mean what does it mean
for our focus is to change on the other
hand as a start-up goes from baby
startup to three-year-old startup the
needs of each role also changes right
the the type of person that you need to
be to get something off the ground that
sort of CEO that you need to be to get
the industry and get folks excited about
this new vision can be a very different
person than that CEO who needs to get to
that repeatable sales model and so I
think because we started off with this
very strong base of trust between the
two of us and understanding of each
other's strengths and skills we have
been able to both do what is best for
the company yeah yeah so just following
for that so I'm really fascinated with
that dynamic and how did conflict
resolution and disagreement said that
just sort of happened naturally did that
take some work and the other part to
that question is and I've talked a lot
about Generation Z and Millennials how
incredibly self-aware but that's that's
an incredibly rare insight to have the
kind of self-awareness to focus on what
the needs of the company aren't be able
to literally adopt and take on a
different role so did would that level
of self-awareness come from and just a
dynamic of how this you know how the
magic of getting his chemistry right
charity is pretty exceptional yeah and
she had been a manager for many years at
parson before and so I all credit for
that self-awareness I think really goes
to her yeah very cool that's awesome
okay third reason why startups fail they
ran out of money and can't raise money
so of the universe of early-stage
companies in the world the last stat
that I looked at maybe 10% if they're
lucky get a meeting with an
institutional investor and I know that
maybe 10% of that actually gets a term
sheet and gets funded so you know
raising money at the level that you guys
have done so walk me through a little
bit how you overcome that challenge - my
guess was people weren't lining up
trying to throw money at you guys and
how you were able to get the company
capitalized
funny she described it much Madeleine
yeah this is another point in favor of
working at an existing company for a
while before jumping into a startup
because charity and I had done our time
worked at a number different companies
because charity had for the last two
years that should spend at Perce really
invested in going doing the conference
circuit and talking about and
becoming sort of a domain expert in
reliability engineering she she
was sort of more of a known quantity and
especially when early-stage startups
also involve bringing in customers and
getting folks to pay attention to you
that was very much a point in our favor
when we were raising our first seed
round and I actually remember one of our
what am I one of my first conversations
was one of our early investors he was
sort of a casual acquaintance and I was
like hey wanted to catch up how's it
going he's like oh I'm so glad you
reached out I heard charity majors left
Facebook do you know what she's doing
next and I was able just sit back and
kind of crack up because like oh well
you asked we're working together on a
startup I hear you have money I think
since then it has you know it only it
only gets harder once they expect you to
have more results to show each step of
the way it's due funding I think it's a
really important institution but they're
at that point they're betting on you
they're betting on your potential
they're betting on your idea and how
excited they are about the market and a
lot of these difficult to quantify
things and one thing that it's certainly
true and that we have been able to
experience ourselves is okay well two
rounds down the road what do you have to
show for it yeah and it's a very
different conversation yeah awesome cool
one of them more challenging so getting
the product right figuring out product
market fit super challenging getting the
right people on board in the right
position it's really hard and getting
the company capitalized the other part
that also is incredibly difficult to
figure out is your go to market strategy
so I'm wondering who your
steamers are how the market segments and
how you've been able to reach your
market how you figured all of that out
and we're able to start establishing
value and generating revenue this has
been an incredible learning experience
for us so again a couple engineers who
knew that it's not as simple as you know
if people that they will come and
certainly at parse we're coming out of
this being like ok well we need to just
charge money first or else we will have
to sell to Facebook because we had no we
don't have enough revenue coming in not
a bad not a bad way to go
I think it has been fascinating so we
started off thinking well of course
we're going to we've always priced per
based on storage a lot of other
customers in the space will do things
like price based on seat price based on
hosts how many hosts you're currently
monitoring and for various reasons we
felt like those were how a pricing
models put in place by business people
and not by engineers and be sort of a
relic of how again systems worked in the
past and how reflection of how
infrastructure looked in the past so
we've always priced based on storage and
we sort of started out with this thesis
that people who have sufficiently
complex infrastructures will need have
the budget and will have the need to pay
for something a tool that really helps
them understand it and I think there has
been a little bit of because of the lack
of a really strong business voice early
on we did a lot of exploration and we
had a lot of early success with folks
who have been around the block tried a
bunch of tools and got it who are like
hey I hear you you're saying like
honeycomb is taking the right approach I
believe in this I'm gonna place a bet on
you almost almost like investors do with
seed station companies and I think the
thing that we discounted in trying to
repeat that is the role of navigating an
organizational structure finding your
way to that buyer from
practitioner who might absolutely get it
but it has no pole in their organization
and so I would say that in 2018
especially the end of 2018 we've gotten
a lot better at first finding kind of a
pressure release valve for those
practitioners who are very excited but
are never gonna be able to justify a
large deal so okay we've released a
self-served here you can self-select
into this you'll have to talk to a
salesperson and you can just get up and
going and on your way at the same time
we've gotten a lot better at
understanding first identifying who our
buyer is what our entry point is who to
talk to and second not framing the value
of Honeycomb in terms of our technical
capabilities but what it will enable
their engineering team to do right very
natural for engineers hey remember how
you want to try to do the thing and you
couldn't and you're on call and and your
life sucks we have the solution that
works really well for the person who's
actually being woken up not so much for
the CTO VP of engineering who's like on
call I remember when I was on call X
years ago and so it has been an
education and a revelation in figuring
out how to speak to that person as well
as how to assemble the right team of
folks to help us speak to that person
because charity and my brains are wired
precisely the wrong way constantly and
so it's it's the unwire constant unring
that we have to do and speaking to
buyers takes a lot of discipline yeah
that's fantastic
so as I look out into the audience I see
future entrepreneurs like yourself what
lessons would you share with them about
your journey what have you really
learned at top you know three things
that you think would be important for a
future entrepreneur I'm going to give
lessons to my my past self who probably
would not have characterized herself as
a future entrepreneur so I'm assuming
all of you the fact that you're here
you're all already past this point I'm
going to say these lessons anyway
because I can
as a technical person it was very easy
for me to be like oh well marketing soft
skills sales soft skills I can figure
those out
and Men I wish I could go find my 18
year old self and like smack myself
upside the head and then make myself go
sit in a marketing class just to
understand how what what playing pieces
you have there what levers you have what
what what people in a different role
care about and how that boundary should
work right because yes I'm technical
that's that's a great advantage to have
but if you don't know if you don't know
what you are missing in these other
roles not only can you probably not do
it yourself
well right away it's also it becomes
much harder to find someone who can and
building the right team hiring we've had
a couple old kind of hiring the steps
along the way because we didn't know
what what good looked like and what we
were missing
another lesson I think I am so you
mentioned the the company I started when
I was 23 in 2011 when I was 23 that
startup was only over myself and my
co-founder my daily I worked 6 days a
week from around 11:00 a.m. until 4 a.m.
every night and I know it was 4 a.m.
because that's when the last bus left
from market back down to Lower Haight
where I lived
consistently Saturday nights I would end
like around like 1 or 2 and I'd like to
do a shot and go meet up with my friends
at a bar there is a level of
sustainability again I'm hoping this is
not news to any of you but there there
are things that you can you can do it
doesn't mean that you should and
probably means that you're not going to
be your best self when you when you when
you when you do them two of our first
employees honeycomb were dads of
toddlers so they had to go home at 5:00
to put their kids to bed I woke up at
4:00 in the morning you know sometimes
they would come back online
and work on their own schedule but I
think with honeycomb we were able to set
the expectation from the beginning like
we are hiring you and in hiring you we
we're extending the trust that you are
going to do your work sustainably and
kind of police yourself right you are
going to not bring yourself out you're
going to be responsible and do all the
things that like you should be doing but
I don't want to be having to tell you to
go home at 2:00 a.m. because it's been
the fourth night and already we've been
at work and I think charity honestly but
this is easy for us to say and charity
and myself again probably have the most
irregular
terrible schedules of everyone in the
company but being able to set that
expectation upfront that we do not
expect it of the company I think has
allowed us to hire a type of person that
lots of companies looking for ninjas and
rock stars it would love to hire but
can't and I think the third thing
actually then for for future
entrepreneurs is don't don't undervalue
the culture of a company when when
starting right lots of lots of other
startup founders will say their biggest
problem is hiring with Honeycomb
granddad we're pretty lean right now but
we I'm lucky we're lucky enough to say
that with the exception of good
marketing people who can who could
market technical products I did I
believe the hardest world to hire for in
the industry we have been lucky enough
to not really have had a problem with
hiring because people come to us because
they know that we respect our engineers
we respect our employees there is an
attitude of humility towards these other
disciplines you're not going to you know
a salesperson isn't going to join
honeycomb and be be like looks down on
because we've gone through and learned
all these lessons and and been made
humble by the rest of the industry and
that they're you know frankly I think
our engineering team hanker entire
company is like half women and that the
these sorts of things that you establish
very early on when it's two founders or
two founders and two employees and
that and plus one problem it
establishing the right culture early and
saying that you care about the things
that you care about early really sets a
tone for hiring far far down the road
farther than you can see
that's awesome fantastic so one of the
and doing some research and looking in
your background talking a little bit
last night and just in this conversation
here today you strike me as a polymath
person someone who is incredibly gifted
obviously incredibly bright but can
grasp and gain a lot of knowledge and a
lot of different disciplines and that's
that's pretty rare I worked with Elon
Musk he was able to do that but one of
the things that I think is a testament
to this ability I'm one of you to tell
the audience a little bit about you know
most folks can either be fantastic at
b2b or super fantastic at b2c like these
are entirely different markets entirely
different needs the fact that you've
been successful in both of those areas
everything about what you learn through
that and how that skill came about it
and how you you know have this ability
to be so successful in b2b and then also
so successful in b2c
I'm gonna I would not say that I would
not characterize myself as successful
and b2c frankly I think b2c is sort of a
consumer is just if the consumers are
fickle and and magical anyone who gets
b2c is basically a future in a way that
I don't I think what draws me to be to
be frankly is the conviction that I
understand the problem and that's that's
the power and being a developer building
developer tools I can immediately
empathize I can I can smell the I don't
have I can swear I can smell that look
the the pitfalls that I might that we
might fall into a little bit better and
I think what I enjoy and and certainly
again my personality rather than I thing
is with b2b we have the a little bit
more of the time and luxury to really
understand our customers to really
understand an account understand what's
special about their engineering team
about their practices about the problems
that face them
that are unique to their business that's
a lot of fun for me and really informs
our product informs how we think about
you know reaching the next few the next
end customers like them and I think I I
think helps them feel like honeycomb is
really one of their partners rather than
just a vendor or a you know some tool
that they use okay cool what's critical
obviously it's recruiting and hiring
really great talent you're as good as
your talent and tell me a little bit
about what do you value more pure raw
engineering talent or domain expertise
and how do you know how does your sort
of recruiting process work and how you
reconcile those two those two items
that's a great question
I honestly would probably say neither
one is the most important for us when
hiring Ranjan air and talent is
important but not the most important
thing I think we and we actually have
some posts on our blog about our hiring
process we would much rather see
understand how someone thinks and
constructing technical interviews is a
topic that I'm sure if you wanted to get
a panel up here and take like three
hours discussing the merits of but
they're there there are so many
dimensions of building software shipping
software as part of a team that white
board interviews simply don't capture I
will call it stripe as another example
of a really great company that does
their engineering interviews in a
slightly different way where they accept
that and we accept that software
engineering is about it's about reading
code probably more than about writing
code it's about pairing with someone to
talk through a problem it's about
understanding the architecture of the
problem and especially for us for
product engineer we want them to be
thinking about what the experience is
for the user we're a small start-up
we're allowed we're right now we're
solar states where we are able to
embrace people who aren't just you know
give me a give me a spec and I'll
execute on it we love people who can be
given a technical problem but make those
trade-offs and make those decisions
based on what they think the the best
user experience is and so
it's you know domain expertise is
something that can be learned again as a
developer tool we have the additional
leg up of lots of people come in
naturally with domain expertise because
they've had to deal with production
incidents on the job and raw an
engineering talent is something that
engineering ladders can address and and
ideally is already happening on the job
but it's the there's there's an element
of curiosity and openness and kind of
acceptance that you have different skill
set than I do we can work together and
pair and build something awesome that
that is I think what gets us much more
excited about an engineering candidate
very cool tell me a little bit about
your culture how you guys built it did
it happen organically was it purposeful
what shaped it how would you describe it
I would say it is fairly purposeful so
again charity myself worked at parse one
of the things I think became very clear
to us was how that parse was very
special to us because everyone who
joined cared deeply about the problem
domain and the way that we were
addressing it and there was a person
part where there's a point when parse is
like 20 people and everyone had built an
app on purse even though even the office
manager like it was just cool and that
was something that was really special
and was something that kind of had
effortlessly come out of those founders
so when charity and I started honeycomb
we were very aware of how the things
that we did things that we signaled were
important to us would shape the culture
moving forward and how how easy it is to
let something spin away with if you've
you're not paying attention to it so
again model you know we start off being
very conscious of visibly visibly and
vocally rewarding the behaviors that we
wanted to support while you know very if
we for example working late right
charity and I worked late all the time
but if one of our engineers who we knew
had a kid was working late would be like
hey you need to get home
like there's
thanks for working late I saw you you
know tried really hard there's no you
know thanks for working at 11:00 p.m. on
things the day before Thanksgiving none
of that
it was very we're very conscious of
those signals that we would send because
even though we knew those first two
hires really well
well that next hire might might pick up
those cues and and learn that well I'm
expected to be here at 11:00 p.m. the
day before Thanksgiving too we think
that's terrible
and I think that that extended to again
work-life balance that extended that
extends to how we want engineers to work
with each other in a very collaborative
style rather than a like leave me alone
style and I think that it's a we are
constantly looking and and and seeing
and course-correcting and we've been
very lucky to hire two hired some
managers who are similarly very
conscious and invested in facilitating a
culture of learning and curiosity to
support the Ranjan earing talent that
all of our engineers have that's awesome
all right we got one final question that
will open up for some Q&A and I'm gonna
steal Tina Seelig
my favorite question go back in time
you're having conversation with your 20
year old self what advice did you give
that person sleep more and have more fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
I worked really hard in college I don't
regret it I'm sure I learned a lot but
like you know if I if my GPA was like a
couple points you know tenths lower
would I have had some more fun probably
would have made a difference to where I
am today probably not I think that in in
life in work it's constantly a game of
prioritization right if I if I I have
these ten to-do items which one is the
one that I can do that I'll have the
most impact so I can go to sleep and not
feel bad about the other nine that's
something that I wish had perfected when
I was in school too so that I could
maximize for learning I could maximize
for I mean the the biggest bang for my
buck
or things that would make my grade still
be good but I look back and I'm like you
know what people talk about things like
Thursday Thursday and I'm like oh I
always had a lab or a giant pset or
something do Friday mornings I had a
very boring Thursday night always yeah
that's awesome fantastic oh look I can
tell you just in a short time that we
spend together unless you've been
snoozing through this thing your energy
your positive attitude it's so
infectious I literally to have such a
technical product like I go work for you
you made it so interesting and so cool
and I hope all of you felt that way as
well I want to thank Christine for an
amazing talk I will tell you I'm just so
impressed with the ability for you to
create your own path it seems like
you've done that your entire life you
create your own opportunities and just
your energy is just exploding here in
this room so let's give Christine a
massive round of applause
[Applause]